Hello, my name is Edward Bennett, and I'm an instructor here at Epic Games.
I'd like to welcome you to this course, Introduction to Runtime Animation for Games.
In this course, we focus on four key objectives.
First, we'll understand how the animation blueprint serves as a framework for managing the character animation.
And we'll explore the structure and learn how they interact with the other animation assets to control character movement.
Next, we want you to be able to create an animation blueprint from scratch.
This involves setting up state machines, variables, and nodes that define the specific animation behaviour and transitions.
Our third objective is to trigger animations from within a blueprint.
So we'll look at how to initiate animations based on a gameplay event.
Like a key press.
Lastly, we'll work on splitting a skeletal mesh, which will allow us to target specific sections of the mesh.
This is crucial for animating parts of the character independently, such as waving hands or nodding a head.
Each of these objectives should build on the last, providing us with a good foundational understanding of animation control.
In the next video, we will start by going over some basic concepts so that you can understand what we're working with.